Chinese foreign minister Wang Yi got his
visit to Russia underway by meeting his
counterpart Sergey lavrov in Moscow the
pair are believed to have discussed
increasing cooperation Hilo shappavalova
has more from Moscow
Chinese foreign minister won his
four-day visit to Russia is a planned
event as part of the Russian Chinese
strategic security consultations during
the meeting with his Russian counterpart
sir galavrov the two diplomats have
exchanged views on the Ukrainian crisis
and discussed security issues in the
asia-pacific region both Russia and
China are quite concerned about growing
military cooperation between the United
States Japan and South Korea the two
foreign ministers were also expected to
discuss Vladimir Putin's negotiations
with North Korean leader Kim Jong-un who
had been recently visiting Russia's Far
East and left the country just the day
before Russia and China planned to
increase their interaction on platforms
such as the U.N brexit G20 and the
Shanghai Corporation organization plus
another topic that was presumably
addressed as we understand was Vladimir
Putin's possible visit to China in the
near future actually a very short part
of their negotiations was released where
the Chinese is foreign minister said
that together with Russia they were
ready to work on the creation of a
multi-polar world and a fair world order
it's planned that Wang e will meet with
Russian Security Council secretary
Nikolai patrechev and perhaps Russian
President Vladimir Putin will also
receive the Chinese top Diplomat but the
Russian side hasn't announced that yet
one is visit to Russia comes on the
heels of his recent meeting with U.S
national security adviser Drake Sullivan
and Malta were the Chinese foreign
minister urged the U.S to fulfill its
commitment not to support Taiwan
Independence